[موسيقى]
هذا موقع احد الانفجارين استهدف محطه
حافله عند مدخل القدس واوقع العديد من
الاصابات
الاسرائيليه التي تواصل جمع الادله كما
نرى في هذه الصور تقول ان الانفجارين
يشتبه بانهما هجوم فلسطيني واقامه بغلق
مداخل القدس من الجهه الغربيه
حاليا لشرطه اسرائيل في معاينه جميع
المناطق التي يحتمل ان تكون خطيره سواء في
محطات الحافلات او في الحافلات نفسها او
المناطق المتحده
متحدث باسم حركه حماس الشاد بالتفجيرين
لكنهم تنهى عن اعلان المسؤوليه
وقال ان ذلك ناجم عن الجرائم التي يرتكبها
الاحتلال والمستوطنون
تفجيراني وقع في الوقت الذي يتفاوض فيه
بنيامين نتنياهو مع حلفاء لتشكيل حكومه
اليمنيه جديده تضم اعضاء من الاحزاب
الدينيه واليمنيه المتطرفه من جهه اخرى و
خلال اشتباكات دارت ليله الثلاثاء
الاربعاء بين الجيش الاسرائيلي ومسلحين
فلسطينيين في مدينه نابلس بالضفه الغربيه
المحتله قتل شاب فلسطيني واصيب اخرون
برصاص جنود اسرائيليين وفق وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه